all the stuff gets down I think I'm all
that intro hi We're
[Music]
remember the art is assuming weapon so
the guy comes in
I don't want to try to draw my weapon so
yeah okay go I don't want to try to draw
my weapon from here because you could
he'll turn and I'm not fair so I tried
it then I decided I'm gonna do over here
and then okay now it's all my way all
right so placement but next practical
priority is disturb it so when I got
right here on my book ringing it is
this happens in an instant
yeah I know again prioritize those
things not that's not what you think the
technique it so here I didn't get it I
don't field enough friction or
connection we have so I wrong here it's
the same thing
I'm just looking for space to draw my
weapon he doesn't even need to fall I'm
going to get to space I'm going to get
to state same thing I decided follow it
down this is not it this is different
even if I don't roll all over that's
where my fainted don't cast yourself
let's take on task yourself with weapons
prioritization this does not do it
you're going to pump down boom and you
create this pace so that's what I'm
going through in the floor same thing
this is not the face the face is over
here this is where I can draw a weapon
it's elbows in front of my centerline
it's on that lead side go